hi miss Coombs we're up here now ma
baker's Nepal me the United States force
and behind me is an old world with
western red cedar at one time the Cedars
went all the way to the sure-lite and
you're a couple thousand years old the
trees were so thick you couldn't walk
through the forest the old growth but
most of the force has been long so
there's quite a few old-growth Cedars
yet but you're hard to come by and so we
work with the u.s. Forest Service here
and there's one tree that fell from this
spot you got undermined by all the wind
and the rain and the snow and it finally
fell but this tree behind me is also
going to fall and it's undermined about
sixty percent of its root wad is exposed
to the elements and so when we talk to
the Forest Service they said we could
have this log for the National Library
of Medicine project as well so really
fortunate to have some elders
illumination and some trained
traditional young person's Navajo Nation
that have come here to help us pray for
this this tree here the one that's
already down
what CF CM the CI a-- it's an alicorn
affiliate a trophy we come here today be
honest this man that's going to take
your home not to take your life but to
give you new life to transform you that
you will bring home peace to our people
throughout the nation
Oh
when we come and take a tree out of the
forest were supposed to be appreciative
was supposed to be respectful we're
supposed to humbly ask permission to
take this tree because the forest is
full of medicine and the cedar tree is
just one more of the medicine people
this totem poles for the national
library of medicine and the story is
about protection and preservation of
traditional knowledge and traditional
medicine totem poles are about symbols
and the symbols usually tightest stories
legends myths folklore it ties to the
some of the traditional knowledge within
a Native community they all have their
stories about their relationship with
the earth and in that relationship over
time they learned about medicine
we're pretty excited about participating
with the National Library of Medicine we
know that they have a national library
as well as regional branches of the
National Library and they also make
themselves available and participate
with local universities different
projects and programs and so as Native
communities we know that we have culture
and we know that we have traditional
knowledge we know that we have knowledge
handed down from generation to
generation about traditional medicines
but we don't know how to protect it most
of the time we learned over the
centuries to keep it quiet and so we're
hoping that the journey as we go to the
various Native communities will create
awareness you know and that will come to
understand that the national library of
medicine is a resource that it has
information that we can access the
utilize also that it's not a one-way
relationship it's not them coming to us
and asking the document and catalog
everything we know it's them coming to
us saying this is what we know no you're
welcome to it you know it has a good
public institution it it has a basic
open door and it's transparent
for native peoples healing is more than
the treatment of physical symptoms you
see native healing is intertwined with
larger concepts such as self-respect
spiritual balance family and a
connection with the land
that's why for native peoples individual
healing cannot be separated from
community wellness they're one in the
same in this exhibition we explore these
native concepts of health and wellness
honoring the native tradition of oral
history we have gathered a chorus of
healing voices from across the country
so that you may hear their stories in
their own words
a reverence for nature is common among
all native peoples unlike modern society
was your ex barriers between itself and
the natural world native cultures derive
strength and healing from the land and
water individual wellness cannot be
achieved when the connection to nature
is missing or contaminated you'll hear
personal stories about the importance of
land water the environment and the
medicinal plants that have been a source
of healing for millennia so this is how
we this is he nahin na kar ke and this
is the movie of the green tea leaf okay
this is for a broken bone
maybe people's believe that each person
has a responsibility for his or her
proper behavior and health these stories
offer ideas about personal
responsibility family and tribal ties
role models and identity our native men
are still leaders in our communities and
days of old they would stand and they
would protect their families they would
die for their women and their children
and what we're saying is do that again
come back and do it today and this time
do it around domestic violence child sex
abuse and child neglect and that for us
as strong men and warriors just like
they did in the days when they had to
stand up and fight your breasts we want
them to do it today
the gathering of the community is a
cherished practice because in a
traditional society the community is a
source of support and healing for native
peoples individual health cannot be
separated from community wellness you'll
hear about the differences between life
on the reservation and life in the city
and attitudes that native people share
regardless of where they're living the
displacement of native peoples cities
has have a profound effect on just their
psyche how they see the world how they
view the world their ability to trust
people their ability to to interact in a
way that allows us to be able to instill
in them a sense of belonging a sense of
well-being that can translate into
better health native peoples live in two
worlds one that honors the ways of their
ancestors and one that acknowledges the
conveniences and challenges of modern
society wellness is sought through the
preservation of languages ceremonies and
burial practices reverence for the
creator of respect for the wisdom of
elders are important traditions that
have survived for millennia you'll also
hear stories of loyalty and military
service that exemplify modern native
traditions of service and patriotism it
was oh nine hundred 10 hit the beach we
maintain communication under all kinds
of fire snipers you name it the officer
or somebody writes the message holy do
is all in English it a message and all
who do is transmitted into a Navajo in
Navajo they'd be not talker we said
close to 800 in four to eight hours came
out perfect taken together these
concepts influence a native person's
approach to good health and inform their
decision whether to pursue Western
medicine or traditional healing
practices when confronted with an
illness well I'm glad we're beginning to
recognize officially the worth of these
native doctors and I'm glad we're doing
this in native americans and indians
also the congress of the united states
is considering a native sovereignty
measured yes which would give them
federal government recognition as we
give to Indians once that is set up I
think one of the high priorities would
be to set up a native hospital to revive
the practice of native medicine for
example I think that's a good thing
you